مشاهدينا الكرام يسعدنا في هذا اللقاء ان
نرحب من جده
بالمعالي الامين العام لجامعه الدول
العربيه سيد احمد ابو الغيط الذي سنستفيد
منه في هذه المقابله بافكار مختلفه سواء
على صعيد انعقاد القمه العربيه والنتائج
المتوقعه منها والمحتمله او على طريقه عمل
الجامعه العربيه وقراراتها اسمحوا لي ان
ارحب بمعالي السيد احمد ابو الغيط معنا
اهلا بك معنا
نلتقي على هامش القمه في جده القمه 32
للقمه العربيه
هل ممكن ان نقول بان هذه القمه احدثت
اختراق على الاقل في موضوع عوده سوريا الى
الجامعه العربيه طبعا احداثه اختراق لانه
رجعت سوريا خلاص النهارده سوريا
عضو كامل العضويه له كل الصلاحيات وكل
الحقوق وكل الواجبات على
الدوله العطر
وبالتالي هي
طبعا هذه العوده
لا تفرض على الدول اعضاء الجامعه نهجم
معين تجاه
الحكومه السوريه هي عاده
بتوافق من الجميع
هناك من سوف يعيد علاقات وهناك من سوف
يتحفظ في اعاده العلاقات هذا امر خاص
بزياده كل دوله لكن عضويتها كامله واعتقد
انها
سببت
غضب لدى اعداء الحكم في سوريا في العالم
الغربي اساسا
والجماعه مضت في هذا الطريق ودول الاعضاء
ماتوا في هذا الطريق ولا يعني
الغضب خلاص هو الامر كذلك وهذه اراده
عربيه طبعا
القضيه السوريه لم تنتهي بعد ولكن هي
عوده سوريا
عوده في سياق
ساعه عربي لتسهيل تسويه الوضع السوري
بسميه الوضع السوري سميه الاشكاليه
السوريه
والحكومه السوريه والحكم في سوريا قابل
بان تكون هذه العوده في سياق بحث في كيفيه
وبالتالي في كيفيه
وبالتالي
العرب طرحوا نفسهم
اساسا
لمساعد للحكومه السوريه
للتواصل الى بر الامان او البر الاستقرار
او بره السلام
في الدول العربيه وتلتقي
موجوده
والسعي العربي هو انكم تتوصلوا لتسويه
سياسيه بين الحكومه وبين
المعارضه المعارضه السياسيه
وتتوصلوا الى لجنه دستوريه
تسعى لصياغه دستور
لسوريا هذا الدستور
يؤدي الى انه يتيح لكافه القوه
الموجوده على المسرح السوري او خارجه من
سوريين
المجتمع المدني السوري انه يساهم في بناء
دولته
السعي اللي ذكرته حضرتك يعني هذه الكلى
الكلمه لا تشير الى انه يمكن يكون في ايه
اوراق ضغط لاي دوله عربيه
موافقت على عوده او لم توافق على عوده
سوريا الجامعه العربيه يمكن نسعى الف سنه
الضغط المعنوي
يعني
هناك
ترحيب
شعبي كبير
بالعوده السوريه هناك
يعني الكثير من التشجيع من الشعب
وانا
استشعره في مدينه زي القاهره ان الجميع
يهنئني شخصيا باعتبار ان ده انجاز
وبالتالي هذا
الاهتمام بهذه العوده
يفرض على الجانب السوري ان يتفاعل بصدق
ومصداقيه مع هو وهو لا مشروطيات بمعنى هي
الدول العربيه اللجنه المشكله من خمس دول
والامين العام الخمس عارفاهم
الاردن
السعوديه
اراء مصر ولبنان انضمت لهم باعتبارها دوله
كوار والامين العام ست اطراف هذه اللجنه
انا فاهم انها هتكتمع قريبا
ستدخل في تفاعل مع الحكومه السوريه وين
النقطه
ما الذي حصل ما هو الذي يعني جعل الدول
العربيه تخشى من شيء ما تريد شيء ما اكثر
تخشى او تريد او تسعى نحو عوده سوريا يعني
ما الذي حصل لماذا الان يمكن
توقيت القمه ساهم جدا في انه الى متى
الى متى
يبقى العرب غير متواصلين مع الحكم في
سوريا
تعقد اجتماعات في كافه
المجتمعات على مستوى الاوم المتحده ده ده
بعد البعد الاخر وانا اشرت ليه في بيان
امام مجلس الوزراء هو
وقوع تطوير تعديل مسار لدول الجوار دول
الجوار
العربي وهم اساسا الدولتين الاسلاميتين
الكبيرتين ايران وتركيا
ايران تواصلت مع المملكه السعوديه الى
تفاهم واتفاق بمساعده من الصين
وتركيا اصلحت
علاقتها مع
الثلاثي العربي اللي كان مشتبك بها في
رفض لسياساتها وتدخلاتها اللي هي
السعوديه والامارات ومصر
مع تحول هذه الدول
هذه الدول نفسها بدات ايضا
تنظر الى سياستها تجاه الاقليم
والدول العربيه بتتفاعل مع هذا فربما في
هذا السياق
اثر باي شكل من الاشكال على هذا القرار او
سرع فيه بنحكي عن ازمه اوكرانيا روسيا عن
ما يحدث في في
الصين الولايات المتحده الامريكيه له اي
علاقه هو ربما لو كان الانسان
بيتصور انه مثل هذه السياسات لمجرد
[موسيقى]
استصاره هذا الطرف او ذاك لا ينبغي ان
يكون هذا هو المنطلق منطلق الاساسي هو
التوقيت انه في قمه في
تحول في سياسات الدول الاقليميه اللي هي
مشتركه على الارض
وانه الاطراف الخارجيه
بتتفاعل مع القضيه السوريه او الاشكاليه
السوريه
والعالم العربي والشعوب العربيه بتبص على
هذا الامر وبتقول اين انتم طب اشمعنى
النقاش بيدور مع سوريا وحول سوريا وانتم
غضبانين من سوريا انا شخصيا انا شخصيا
عندما
حدثت احداث
تجميد العضويه السوريه ما كنتش وزير
خارجيه لمصر وبالتالي كنت انظر من الخارج
وقت انظر بغضب كيف نسمح بذلك
يعني لانه تجميد عضويتها
سيدفعها بعيدا عن امتها وده عضو
فاعل ومش بس عضو فاعل وعضو منشئ للجامعه
العربيه كان ينبغي انه احنا نتمسك به
الحديث
باستمرار التشاور معها ولا غضب اطلاقا ولا
ياس اطلاقا لانه
المنطقه هدرت عشر اعوام او 12 عاما
في
في ماساه كبرى وصلت الى ما وصلت اليه يعني
بعض الناس تقول لي ايه ده الربيع العربي
ده شيء عظيم
طبعا انا ما بسموش ربيع انا بسميه التخريب
العربي او التدمير العربي لكن ايه بقى
الشيء العظيم في قتل
300 الف سوري
ونزوح
ولجوء ملايين خارج اراضيهم ايه الربيع
فيما حدث في اليمن
لانه الكوليرا
وشلل الاطفال يرجعهم لدول عربيه فشلت
وسقطت زي ما شفنا في
ليبيا وشفنا في اليمن وشفنا في سوريا هل
يمكن ان نقول ان القضيه الفلسطينيه
قد تكون تحولت بعد ما حدث في الربيع
العربي بين قوسين مره اخرى الى مجرد شعار
يعني اصبح الاهتمام بالقضايا الداخليه
العربيه اهم الاهتمام بالقضيه الفلسطينيه
الشعب الفلسطيني شعب حي عايش موجود على
الارض
ولن يقطع عليه ولن يقضى عليه
[موسيقى]
اليمين الاسرائيلي
والحكومه الاسرائيليه
واتجاهات في اسرائيل متصوره انه
استمرار قتل الفلسطينيين سوف يسمح
بانسانيا وقانونيا وسياسيا وتاريخيا وسوف
نقتلهم ثم نقتلهم ثم نضربهم ثم نضربهم
لمره انا مره كان في كونجرس مان في
في الكونجرس الامريكي وانا وزير خارجيه
وقال لنا في شرم الشيخ في احد المؤتمرات
وجاء ذكر القضيه الفلسطينيه
بيقول لي نحن نضربهم ده
امريكي يهودي امريكي يهودي نحن نطربهم
ونضربهم ولا يسلمون
كان معي السفير حسام زكي كان 2009
بسنت كده قلت له ولا حاجه
افرضوا عليهم الاستسلام ما انتم خليتوا
اليابان تستسلم وخليته المانيا لهتلاريه
النازيه تستسلم
حاولوا
بس استطيع ان انا اؤكد لك
انه
هذا الشعب
لن يستسلم قط وبالتالي انا مؤمن بان الشعب
الفلسطيني موجود
طيب مش عاوزين تدولو حقه في الدوله
خلاص
ننتظركم لغايه عام 2050 النهارده
ننتظركم ايه 27 سنه كمان ننتظركم
ننتظركم 37 سنه كمان
لما عدد الفلسطينيين في المنطقه من نهر
الاردن
للبحر الابيض المتوسط يعني الضفه الغربيه
وعرب
اسرائيل او فلسطين بنسميهم الفلسطينيين
اللي هم مقيمين في دوله اسرائيل من 48
يكون عددهم 2050
12 مليون
وعدد اليهود
ثمانيه مليون
تسعه مليون
فرجونا بقى ما يتحدث به العالم الغربي من
مفاهيم
بيطبقوها على نفسهم وبيكذبوا بها على بقيه
البشريه كلمه ايه القيم
القيم الغربيه تفرض اننا نتصدى ضد هذا وضد
ذاك طب فرجونا بقى قيم الديمقراطيه هتقود
الى ايه في وقتها وبالتالي هتبقى يا اما
دوله
يا اما دوله يحكمها رئيس الوزراء
من اصل فلسطيني السودان في امل هدات
المعارك يومين واشتعلت في اليوم الثالث
مساله السودان
يجب ان احنا نتفهم
يعني ايه وجود دوله
لها مؤسسات لها حكومه لها رئاسه لها
سلطتها
وما بين هذه المؤسسات هي قوات مسلحه
القوه المسلحه
الرسميه للدوله لا يتصور انه يكون فيه لها
شريك او خصم او طرف اخر من القوه المسلحه
فدائما مثل هذا النوع من التواجد احدهما
يتغلب على الاخر
السياق العام اللي احنا كنا متابعينه
قريينه وبنتابعوا انه كان في اطار
بيتم التفاوض عليه انه
قوه التدخل السريع هتخش جوه الجيش صحيح
واختلفوا على او اختلفوا شكلا على الفتره
هيحتاجها هذا الاندماج لكن عندما تبين
الاطراف انه لا يمكن ما يحصلش بشكل
بايقاع عالي كان الصدام حتمي كان الصدام
حتمي ده ده نقطه بس النقطه التانيه انه
عندما يعني يتحدث السلاح احيانا البشر
تتصور ان السلاح حيحسم الامر وهو ده اللي
بيؤدي الى هدنه ثم اقتتال ثم عدنا ثم
اختتال لكن الماساه الكبرى انه
شعب السودان
يعاني معاناه اصلا كان بيعاني وكان بيعاني
ماساه انسانيه المجتمع السوداني يجب ان
ينظر الى نفسه في الداخل ويصل الى حقائق
كيف تحرك خارج هذا الصيام اذا سمحت
لمعاليك الجامعه العربيه ككيان صحيح هي لا
تعبر عن قيام شكيان مستقل هي ايرادات
الدول داخل الجامعه العربيه
تقف خلف البرهان واللحم التين
ولا الفرقه والحمد ولكن الجامعه العربيه
في قراراتها الاخيره منذ بدء الازمه هي
بدات بطلب واقفه اطلاق نار
ثم بدا الموقف يتطور في سياق تطوره في
قرار امام القمه اقر من مجلس وزراء
الخارجيه اليوم
اقر من مجلس وزراء الخارجيه الاسبوع
الماضي في
القاهره ومن اجتماعات المندوبين بتتحدث عن
المؤسسات الرسميه
وضروره الحفاظ على المؤسسات الرسميه
في السياق هذه المؤسسات الرسميه للقوات
المسلحه طبعا
لكن ابرزها واهمها لا نستطيع ان احنا نقول
انه الجامعه بتتبنى موقف هذا الطرف او ذاك
هي بتطلب وقف اطلاق نار وانهاء هذا الوضع
باسرع وقت ممكن والمضي والمملكه العربيه
السعوديه بتسعى لجمع هذه الاطراف للتحدث
فيما بينهم
في الاول بدات وقف اطلاق نار ثم
التوافق على على مواقف انسانيه طبقا
للقانون الدولي الانساني
وبناخدهم بعد ذلك في خطوه المملكه يعني
خطوه اضافيه انه
دعونا
نشوف
نعمل وقف دائم لاطلاق النار ثم بدء
مفاوضات
النهارده اجتمعنا مع الوزير سامح شكري
والوصيل والوزير
وزير الخارجيه
السعوديه
الاميره الامير فيصل بن فرحان
لانه في لجنه ثلاثيه من السعوديه ومصر
والامين العام كيف
نتحرك مع الاطراف وكيف واستمعنا التقرير
لما يبذل سعوديا
وهنتابع هذا الموضوع ان شاء الله سؤال
الاخير قبل ان ننهي هذه المقابله معاليك
الحقيقه الملفات العربيه لا تنتهي الحديث
فيها يطول كثيرا لكن على وقتك احنا عاملين
مقابله نص ساعه ولا 20 دقيقه ولا ما اعرفش
قد ايه ممكن ياخذ
ضعف صحيح بس سؤال اخير اذا بتسمح لي يعني
بسالك كمفكر وليس كسياسي او دبلوماسي وانت
معروف بانك مفكر كبير في العالم العربي
تتصور انه سنصل في مرحله ما نحن هنا في
هذه المنطقه في العالم العربي ان نتمتع
فيها بالاستقرار رفاهيه اقتصاديه وضع افضل
مما نعيش الان في ناس تحلم بدول
اسكندنافيه مثلا المنطقه العربيه تعرضت
المعرفه والمعرفه بيساهم فيها الاعلام
ويساهم احنا في الحته دي لدينا قصور
والاعلام بتاعنا لديه قصور ونادرا ما يعني
امسكي انت البعد الاقتصادي في الجامعه
العربيه بعد الاجتماع في الجامعه العربيه
نتحدث ونجتهد ونبذل ولنا نتائج وهناك
نجاحات وانجازات ولا احد يطلع الانسان
العربي على ما يدور لانه هو التفكير هي
القضيه الفلسطينيه
يعني الازمات
وبالتالي
التعليم اساسي في المنطقه العربيه ويجب ان
يكون التعليم اساسي
التطوير الخطاب الديني تطوير الخطاب
الديني شيء رئيسي في هذه المنطقه لاطلاق
طاقات العرب
والخروج من
القيود
للجن عمره ما حطها الدين الحنيف الحقيقي
محطهاش وبالتالي
الطريق طويل وفي نقاط كثيره مكافحه الفساد
محاربه بين الدوله الفساد الفساد من الدول
العربيه
بيهلك المجتمعات الف شكر معاليك على هذه
المقابله الخاصه لقناه العربيه شكرا شكرا
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات